- Ces images de la télé chinoise
montrent un semblant de retour
à la normale dans les grandes
villisisisis il y a clairement
moins d'achalandage sur
les routes, dans les marchés
et les centres commerciaux.
"L'impact de l'épidémie
sur l'économie est évi
dit-il, mais les investissements
permettent de maintenir 62 %
des activités dans le secteur
de la construction."
Mais la majoritususususines
et des commerces tournent
au ralenti. Des millions
de Chinois sont sans emploi,
barricadés dans leur petit
logement pendant des semaines.
(propos en mandarin)
Dans cette vidéo,
qui n'est pas authentifiée,
un résident se fait emmener
de force dans un centre
de traitement, probablement
parce qu'il ne s'est pas fait
tester ce jour-là et n'a pas
de résultat négatif à montrer.
(propos dadadadarin)
Ce dirigeant du Centre
de contrôle des infections
affirme que la colère exprimée
lors des protestations
cible l'application
trop zélée du confinement.
Une rare reconnaissance
officielle du ras-le-bol
des Chinois, que la répression
massive déployée depuis
le weekend, ne réussit
pas à étouffer.
"Est-ce que des forces
étrangères vous ont dit
de ven? ? ? ? Non!",
répond la foule d'étudiants
rassemblée à Pékin lundi soir.
Le gouvernement chinois accuse
des puissances étrangères d'être
à l'origine des troubles.
"De quelles forces
étrangères parlez-vous,
scande un étudiant, de
Marx, Engels, Stalin, Lenin?
Je tiens à dire que j'aime
mon pays. Le problème, ce sont
les politiques actuelles."
(cacophoni
Le régime chinois réagit
aux pressions de la rue.
Il est désormais interdit de
mettre des cadenas auxssss
pour empêcher les gens de
sortir, et on va intensifier
la vaccination des personnes
âgées de plus de 70 ans, qui
sont encore peu immunisées.
Chez les plus de 80 ans,
seulement 20 % sont pleinement
vaccinés et ils reçoivent
des vaccins chinois,
moins efficaces que
ceux de Pfizer et Modern
qui sont interdits en Chine.
"Je ne suis pas vaccinée,
dit cette femme de 83 ans,papape
pulmonaire, mais si mon médecin
pense que je dois l'être,
je me ferai vacciner."
"Je suis vacciné,
dit cet homme de 79 ans, parceqr
l'économie. Si on reste confiné,
l'économie va souffrir."
L'explosion des cas de COVID,
ces dernières semaines,
semble inciter Pékin
à opter pour une plus grande
vaccination, ce qui réduit
les besoins de confinement.
Ici Sophie Langlois,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.